when people are trying to sell stuff
people start from the outside so it's so
easy to say I don't have time it's the
easiest thing it's out of time everyone
show them how that's a fallacy it's a
distortion of reality you peel that back
you get one layer closure that my wife
won't let me and you peel that out
because five years from now if you
didn't do the things that you wanted to
do with your life because she wouldn't
let you do it you're gonna buy it part
is that fair so I think what you're
doing is you're asking permission
instead of supports play this out right
it's not going to go the way you think
it's going to go because if you keep
repeating this habit you're going to end
up five years from now you're going to
look at your life the same way you're
looking at now and hating finally you're
the person who's squirming there force
them to confront reality which is now
they don't want to make the decision
right because they're like I'm just
going to avoid it I'm not sure Etc et
cetera and you're like hold on finally
when they're in the avoidance part the
biggest fear they have is making a
mistake they don't want to be seen as
stupid it's making them understand you
don't need time to make a decision you
need information if the only source of
the information you have is me let's
talk what are the variables you can use
to make the decision